banks are one of the engines of the
modern economy
but the way they work is under threat
tech payment giants and digital
currencies are revolutionizing how
people use money
and this could have dramatic
consequences far beyond banking
it could affect consumer privacy
government power
and the stability of the entire
financial system
it is difficult to overstate sort of how
radically different that world could be
from the one that we
live in now so what would a world
without banks look like
and would you even miss them
the fundamental principles of banking
have been the same for centuries
and revolve around the greatest magic
trick of all
how to create money it's called
fractional reserve
banking here's how it started
hundreds of years ago banks stored gold
for investors
but they realized it was unlikely
everyone would claim their gold back
at the same time so they began to loan
some of these gold deposits out to other
people
this made money for the bank through
interest and helped power the economy by
allowing idle deposits to fuel
new business and trade as time went on
the banks started issuing
banknotes or ious rather than physically
giving out gold
and these ious started being traded in
the economy
this meant the amount of money in
circulation was much
larger than the value of the gold held
by the banks
so the bank's lending had in effect
created
new money nowadays most money is digital
when the bank makes a loan it creates a
new asset
on its balance sheet and credits the
borrower's account with new funds
which creates a new deposit
the fundamental principle is the same
every time the bank makes a new loan it
creates
new money in fact ninety percent of
money in the world is digital deposits
that have been created by
banks in this way this is hugely
important for the economy
what it means is that banks are able to
respond
to demands for money in an economy and
that means that their supply of money in
economy
is very elastic there is no
set amount of money in circulation so
if the economy is booming and more goods
are being created
then thanks to fractional reserve
banking the supply of money should also
increase
as people take out loans and make new
investments
the ease with which commercial banks can
create money
is largely controlled by central banks
like the federal reserve
which set interest rates if interest
rates are high
banks pass those costs onto borrowers
this makes it more expensive for them to
borrow money to buy
things and so banks create less
new money central banks also supply
money for use in the economy
they print the physical paper cash
people carry around
and so banks and central banks balance
the need to create
money between them that sort of balance
means that you know money can grow
easily with demand but also that the
central bank has sort of
direct presence in payments and
transactions
but this delicate balance is under
threat
thanks to a revolution in the way people
use money
for a start an increasing number of
businesses no longer rely on banks for
loans
this is because businesses historically
used to create concrete assets
like machinery against which banks were
happy to lend
they could always claim the assets if
the borrower stopped repaying
you know you're reliable
but intangible assets like software
can't be easily posted as security for a
bank loan
the world has shifted in a way that does
make it hard for banks to fund
the sort of most innovative parts of the
economy
if you want to get funding as a silicon
valley startup
in general you'll need to go to people
who are
equity investors so they take a slice of
your business
in return for some money
and it's not just innovative startups
that are turning elsewhere for funding
since the 1950s the share of bank loans
as a percentage of gdp
has been relatively stable at the same
time
non-bank loans and securities have risen
sharply
this means the role banks play in
financing important businesses
is receding and that's not all
the way people move and spend their
money is changing too
thanks in part to a new class of mega
apps from china
one of the most popular is alipay from
chinese tech giant
ant group it has over a billion users
and handles 16 trillion dollars in
payments in 2019.
i am alipay i have a dream
to create a world where mobile payment
replaces cash payment
rather than using bank cards to make
payments alipay customers carry out
transactions by loading money into
digital wallets
they can then do anything from buying
lunch to investing in stocks and shares
all without leaving the app and rather
than paying expensive international
transaction fees to their bank
alipay users can also use the app
overseas
you're already seeing this even even in
america you know
walgreens in the states except alipay
this sort of new digital payments
uh ecosystem sort of completely
disregards nation states and national
borders
it's not just alipay facebook is
developing its own digital currency
and amazon is also working on financial
services
some worry this could concentrate too
much power
in the hands of a few tech companies
but for central bankers the problem is
even more acute
they fear these developments could cut
the cord between the central bank
and the economy altogether the super
apps in china they now they started off
as doing payments and now they do
provision of loans they do provision of
investment services they provide
insurance you know they do all the
things that banks do
central bankers feel as though their
sort of ability to oversee
and conduct monetary policy and
oversight
is you know fundamentally slipping away
so some central banks have taken radical
action
by creating their own digital currencies
to rival the tech giants payment systems
in the hope this will secure their grasp
on the economy
central bankers level of discomfort is
potentially prompting them
to sort of act to change this you know
economic system the monetary system that
has underpinned
uh modern economies for you know 250
years
china is one of the largest economies
leading the way
by trialling a digital um
you might have heard of bitcoin or other
digital money
that is supposed to disrupt finance but
digital currency issued by governments
in this way
might be even more radical here's how it
works
most central bank money is held by
commercial banks
as reserves against customer deposits
you can only access
a small amount of this government-made
money via physical notes and coins
as this physical cash is issued by the
central bank
in the uk bank notes are even signed by
the chief cashier of the bank of england
a central bank digital currency or cbdc
is a bit like digital cash as it gives
the consumer a direct relationship with
the central bank
so in theory instead of keeping your
money in a commercial bank
you could hold all your money in the
federal reserve or the bank of england
cbdcs are only being used or trialled in
a handful of countries worldwide
but they're growing fast 80 percent of
central banks are considering issuing
them in the future
the bank of international settlements
which is a club of central bankers says
that uh within three years
a fifth of the world will live in
countries that have
this central bank digital money this
could change
everything if everyone put their money
into a cbdc
then fractional reserve banks could
potentially be out of a job
this could affect economic growth as
they could not rely on consumer deposits
to finance their loans
and this would be particularly
pronounced in the developing world
where most lending still comes from
banks
but that's just the beginning there are
also
concerns about potentially
you know cyber warfare because if you
can take down
the servers that support the central
bank digital
wallet system then you could shut down
an entire economy digital currencies
could also
increase the potential for state
intervention in everyday transactions
it becomes much easier for governments
to completely
block your ability to pay for something
it's very easy to imagine
that you know perhaps you could program
uh you know money in china so that it
can't be used to pay
for books or newspapers from foreign
sellers
supporters of cbdc's claim they could
lead to a world where more people have
access to financial services and it's
cheaper and easier to move money across
borders but innovations like this
could also disrupt the financial
equilibrium
and give governments far greater control
over their citizens money
and lives so although it's possible for
the first time in modern history
to imagine a world without banks you
might just find you'd miss them
if they were gone i'm alice forward the
wall street correspondent for the
economist
if you would like to read more about the
future of banking i've written a special
report
on the subject that you can find by
clicking the link and thank you for
[Music]
watching